so much Wilder
so much bigger boy my mind shooting it I
can't believe I'm standing and it's only
week three only ET was on the set to get
all the scoop on season 2 of unreal
we loved season 1 of this deliciously
devious show and star shiri Appleby who
plays Rachel and Constance immer aka
Quinn
tell me season 2 will take things to the
next level I'm always surprised at what
we're allowed to get away with and and I
think more importantly what Quinn is
allowed to get away with so always makes
me uncomfortable I'm like really really
I'm good to say that okay
he's black and you want him dating white
girls
oh please gonna be making deep dark
nasty love to them too how much is she
stepping up her manipulation in season 2
her fiance died a year and a half ago
ask her did you kill him oh it's a
totally different game this year there's
not quite as much guilt about it and
she's like really smart putting the
pieces together and it's really about
watching her survive now she is the
showrunner of every lashes okay how
about we make a TV show it's been so
great to see the dynamic between Rachel
and Quinn that's who of you together
terrified
thank you what is their dynamic gonna be
like moving forward if she's very
volatile and clearly not ready to give
up the helm we're starting off there's a
bit of tension going on I mean I
definitely am running the show and she's
giving me a little bit of leeway but
wants her personal like messes things up
Rachel's Rachel's huge accomplishment it
kind of becomes just a game for her
incredibly dark and dangerous really
yeah
there's a lot of betrayal happening it's
it's it's it's like heartbreaking but
they still have to work together and
make a show together so that's why I
think the relationship is so fun to play
because they can't one just can't go oh
you know what okay this is it I gotta go
sorry Kirstie